yeah like i suppose unlike us you moved
here post covered all right so i'm i'm
curious what the procedure for you was
like oh yeah i forgot we uh talked about
yeah we went
we went on a tangent we do that a lot
here on trash taste yeah okay yeah so so
take us through the take us through the
process oh yeah it was it was a first oh
voice quick
anyways uh i put in the video
because you you told me it was like it
was a painful process and i was like hey
it can't be that bad and then like you
know it's fine we're just chilling
waiting for the board to open but then
when it actually opened it was it was
such a pain it was like you signed
one paper yeah the same information yeah
and then you have to do that 20 more
times yeah yeah and then you have to
like i had to drive to the borough which
is only in boston drive all the way
there oh the embassy the embassy and
then the lady was like who's this gaijin
trying to get into her country like she
treated me like trash i was like yeah
fair enough like i understand
i understand a lot and then she's like
come back a week drive back and then
drive it again yeah get that thing it's
very frustrating to go to the embassies
especially if they're far away yeah when
they're far away you don't know like how
they operate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then that
whole deal happened and then yet
luckily i had passport already but then
one of the annoying parts the covid they
call it my sos it's like an app where
you have to get into oh yeah
what's super troll about this is that
when i got to the airport when i landed
in japan the app stopped working and
then all these people who like couldn't
communicate with me were like
why is your phone not working and i was
like it's not just me like all these
other people's like apps aren't working
yeah that's all the app is really buggy
yeah it's funny [ __ ] yeah so then they
like sent me to a computer to put the
same information i did like 37 times
yeah try to do it again
and then
yeah so to explain uh this is this is
the app i just have it as well because i
just came into japan
did i call you uh they don't call me
because i don't need to quarantine that
was really i'm boosted they like called
me you're boosted
i'm boosted baby
yeah they called me they and they
checked on me like every day when i came
back yeah yeah they caught me on stream
and i i i did it yeah yeah
last time when we needed to quarantine
they call you every day but i believe
like now you just have to download it
just to register that you are coming
into the country
if it works i mean like i i felt like i
i i go like because i've done this
before and i did it through like hard
mode right when i came in we would like
literally treated like cattle like they
would give us they would like we come in
and they like tag us and brand us and be
like those yeah those are the people
coming in and we
we literally spent four hours in the
airport and like how long did you spend
in the airport very quick well not quite
quick because you know the whole like
yeah we're gonna be three hours that's
pretty good you're getting the visa yeah
if you were getting there yeah yeah and
you're getting the visa as well
uh can i talk [ __ ] about delta is that
one yeah you can talk [ __ ] about it
we're not sponsored
so that's literally our partner
actually yeah [ __ ] delta dude
i've i've wrote with them three times
they [ __ ] me over all three times
anyways they delayed my [ __ ]
um
flight my flight yeah and what the thing
is that you needed the covet test oh oh
yeah yeah well you get results in two
days yeah so i had to time it perfectly
yeah and then when i did time it
perfectly delta canceled my japan trip
they put they made me get stuck in
detroit i'm like literally just stuck in
detroit all night yeah and then when i
got to the airport
they were like
hey uh your covet test is late by a day
and then i had to show my ticket like yo
they delayed me by a whole day and they
had to bring the manager and then the
manager had to bring the other manager
and then the manager managers had to
bring the other manager and he came over
and he's like okay you're good
that's the most japanese story i've ever
heard in my life
and i'm like just get me in the goddamn
country already like i'm tired i'm
sweaty yeah uh yeah see i i think i
think i must have taken like the most
optimized path you could possibly get to
take in the country because i was only
at the airport for like an hour and a
half but like i i prepared my covert
tests i made sure like it was dated and
timed and made sure to print out all my
tickets yeah did you did you
pre-register as well i did you did i did
and it didn't work it wasn't working and
and i even screenshotted the barcode oh
yeah but so was it was the app green
um
no because only one of them was wasn't
accepting my vaccine yeah yeah yeah yeah
so you need to make sure you get like
the right kind of vaccine card and then
if you get the right kind of vaccine
card uh the app will turn green and like
if they see a green app they're just
like let this man through let this man
through he's not a green card he's done
the paperwork he's done the paperwork
get him through
yeah
yeah literally i think i skipped like
like an hour and a half to two hours
just because i was able to get the green
app good job
yeah because i i knew how anal like
japan were with documents so i'll just
like i need to make sure every document
is
on par with their exact specifications
when you do something in the uk and i
assume the us sometimes you read some
stuff guidelines you're like i'm sure
that's not that important right like in
japan if it's written there they're
going to check yeah yeah yeah they will
check they will make sure japan is the
only country where like you actually
have to read the fine print yeah because
they do everything the fine prince i i
uh i did i went above and beyond and i
still got like
that's
kind
for you that is japan it's japan so so
yeah
you still took three hours just because
you had to like re-sign everything and
read oh actually the day before that
when i transferred it to uh
detroit yeah they kept they kept being
like oh we're gonna get another pilot
one hour later oh the pilot's coming one
hour later three hours later and then
they go oh cancelled and then like
here's your hotel go to the hotel waste
a whole last day go the next day and
then you know finally load then i got
the airport three hours and then mainly
picked me up and i was like
and then i met you guys at the uh that
that restaurant
yeah pretty mid yeah
i i gotta say since uh dardis and emily
came like at like after geeksplus has
already obviously been formed for a
while oh they got the [ __ ] vip
treatment coming into japan they got
picked up right at the airport by maylin
and geeks plus staff you know like i i
believe emily got the same treatment
where me and connor we were just left to
like find a way to like our house
yeah fine joey basically i had to pick
the house i'd be like guys i texted joey
when i landed then he felt like okay can
you come help me i've got so many bags
and then he helped me out in like
nippori yeah yeah
and like joey was the one who took care
of it and i remember that because i
remember i was trying to do the same
thing to connor because we were like me
and sydney were going to stay around
connor's house right and conor was kind
of just like yeah joey helped me with
these bags and everything like that so
have i told it on the podcast yeah okay
about me not helping you guys yes i
didn't know you had that many bags i
would have helped if i know
the most [ __ ] up thing i hadn't even
joined geek's boss
yeah back then geeks plus was just
mailing and now geeks plus is an entire
team so of course
i'm surprised they put them up in a
hotel yeah yeah we were we were the beta
chess
hotel joey
i stayed in hotel connor
slept on this floor you know that was
very luxurious
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
technically it is a floor authentic it's
not four generations old actually
handcrafted
so once you got in the country
everything was good you reckon
well
i mean we always needed a translator we
like really like translated like yeah
yeah like everything literally yeah that
was joey's job at the beginning yeah i
wasn't even paying for it yeah i wasn't
even paying for it we're lucky because
you guys are like already established so
you you guys go oh you want to go out to
here yeah yeah okay and then you do all
the speaking and i'm just like
yeah and then uh well we did our first
lesson like
two weeks ago but then golden week hit
yeah yeah just like oh you're going to
japanese lessons yeah yeah oh no that's
for sure for sure i i i feel so useless
man
i really doesn't make you feel like a
like an infant i just can't do anything
yeah i just i feel so i never felt so
useless in my life but that's what i
like about it it's like um you like that
no no
i don't want to do anything let everyone
else do everything
that's cool though because like i don't
know many people who have like
never left their country who are
suddenly just like yeah you know what
i'm just gonna live in a character i've
never been to you know if you live in
your mom's basement basement long enough
you just you just you want to
i've been there
for a very long time right right right
right i mean but like rent is like
insane in the u.s right getting a place
to rent it's my mom's basement so yeah
it's like if you wanted to leave your
mom's basement like the rent is really
high
it depends on what state you're in it
depends where you are
i don't know what it's like in maine but
i guess like new york man it's getting
cheaper i'm not more expensive because
the hipsters are moving in right it's
kind of like williamsburg they they made
it super expensive i mean i know like
new york is like [ __ ] great
actually i when i went to brooklyn i
used to be uh
you just be cheap and and ghetto and
then i came back like you know a couple
years after college and it like
completely you know it was like super
fun it turned fancy i was like where's
my ghetto brooklyn that i missed i
missed the ghettoness where is it
yeah i've heard it's become like the art
district of new york right like it's
like like a lot of hipsters like living
in brooklyn i really think it's it's the
art colleges like yeah